[? SPEAKER: ?] What does
human flesh taste like?
Well, based on the
testimonies of some convicted
modern-day cannibals,
we have a small idea.
Some of these
man-eaters have compared
the taste and texture to pork,
or veal, or even chicken.
Now we might not all agree on
what human flesh tastes like,
but one researcher wanted
to at least find out
if we have any
nutritional value.
By examining bite and stone
tool marks on ancient bones,
archeologists have determined
that some of our ancestors
were cannibalistic at times.
We don't really know how
prevalent cannibalism was
or why some might
have practiced it,
but the new study has
shown that those who did
eat people probably weren't
doing it for sustenance.
Because it turns
out, eating human
isn't that good
for you, at least
compared to other food options.
To get to this conclusion,
one archaeologist
looked to previous
studies at the protein
and fat content
of four adult men
plus the weight of body
parts to calculate out
our caloric value.
This new calculation
found that the modern man
may have a nutritional value
of about 143,771 calories.
He also broke it down
further by body part
with adipose
tissue, or body fat,
with the highest
number of calories,
and the teeth with the lowest.
But remember, this is
taking weight into account.
So you would actually
get more calories
by eating a kilogram
of teeth than you would
a kilogram of lungs or spleen.
Now one note to make is,
these numbers are based
of modern man and
not ancient man
and are specific to adult
males, not women or children.
So obviously, it's not
the complete picture.
But based on these
numbers, it wouldn't
be a smart choice
as an early human
to try to live off of humans.
Looking at muscle
tissues, animals
around at the time like
mammoths, woolly rhinos,
red deer, bears, horses,
boars, reindeer, and even ibex
would offer more calories
than another early human man.
So then, why did
they eat each other?
Well, some think it was a
wartime or religious ritual.
It may have been
opportunistic, easier
to eat someone who died your
group than to go out and hunt.
But according to
this study, it sounds
like early cannibalism was
more cultural and social
than it was nutritional.
[MUSIC PLAYING]